when I went to this therapy group a
couple years ago there were a couple
people in the group that were
rageaholics and they were court ordered
to to be there because they didn't have
a handle off their rage and one lady had
like jumped out of the car in the middle
of freeway and like pulled another lady
out of her car and beat the [ __ ] out or
some [ __ ] like that
that rageful but even the knowledge of
like you know how you're talking about
that one second like reactionary time
they were able to break it down to make
it make it look like visually for us how
long and how many like chemical how many
processes bodily processes you we
actually go through before in that one
second before we make that bad decision
right and I think for her that was
really helpful is to see that it's not
just a second it's actually a long time
right if you you can make a choice in
that time and you're also making mini
calculations because like I'm sure
you've all been in the situation where
you try to buck up on someone then you
assess who you've just mucked up on and
now you're immediately able I did that
once on the Britt st. Britt I pulled up
somebody cut me off I pulled up I was
like I and I looked in and it was like
four thug ass [ __ ] oh I'm not
trying to be disrespectful one moment
before I was like the gangster of the
Bay Bridge and now all of a sudden I'm
like a dip like you know it's like if
you can make the calculation that's what
I really realized it's like I've gotten
into situations before with people that
I've deemed physically weaker than me I
know it's hard to believe there are any
but I've made the calculation and that
feels worse than anything well I have
one friend in particular who one time he
said something to me and I just like
started threatening him and I like I'll
beat your ass all this like so the
[ __ ] stupid Oakland programming you
know and yeah I saw his I'll knock you
out it's like stupidest [ __ ] and then I
go I wouldn't have done that if that guy
was bigger which means he I'm a coward
it means I'm a pathetic coward I assess
him I was like you're not a threat to me
physically now I can really like yeah
make that calculation how come you can't
make the secondary calculation of like
I'm just not gonna I'm not gonna do it
like think about how many people are in
jail right now because of a moment that
they that is the most meaningless and
meaningful moment of their lives that's
like my entire Filipino family somehow
someone always finds an ice pick someone
always gets stabbed it's our weapon of
choice nice
everywhere at least for males in my
family during an altercation has found
an icepick as if they're just available
everywhere yeah
but I'll tell you what okay to bring it
back to the child thing yeah I'll tell
you what you can take I don't know why
I'm giving you counseling but I'll tell
you what you can take some solace from
in terms of your you're worried about
your family and they're ice picks yeah
you know their collection of ice picks
in my experience so far child raising a
child is not reactionary it's not
momentary it's the like I said you see
the baby when it's a slug and then it
goes gurgle gurgle and then it goes dad
died and then it goes dad does tired and
then it goes dead will you read me a
story and then it you know it's like
everything is it's slow and it unfolds
and so you don't you're it's not a
momentary reaction it's a it's a process
a slow process so you can you can even
watch the trauma come and say I'm not
gonna bring that here I'm not gonna
explain like shaken bait shaken baby
syndrome then and how like mostly it's
like the dads that give a subdural
hemotoma ridging how do I explain that
yeah like you know how they know I have
an explanation shakes or baby it's a
common thing hey when I Billboard to say
don't shake your baby yeah but I don't
know why you would go because we think
it's not a big shake a very little shake
this do this and that's it three
positions no I do the the chokehold I
did in San Francisco I'll do like a
Kimura I mean I can't speak to people
that are literally mentally incapable of
raising children like I don't think
that's you that's very obviously not you
yeah we're not gonna do that [ __ ] people
that shake their baby to death [ __ ]
baby I'm so afraid of myself I think I
saw you with Jessica's baby you're like
it's a big jesus [ __ ] yeah do you have
God Jesus [ __ ] guy just so my favorite
alternative and is wait do you have pets
I have six you have second do you often
share
them to death no never one I've never
hit nothing we are so have they Ramiro
angry yeah do my [ __ ] dog just bit
the [ __ ] out of me yesterday so you have
the capability of not killing a
defenseless an impressively well am i
postulate that you will like your baby
even more than your sick your to then
you're too many pets you know I think
probably you know I mean the people that
do that kind of [ __ ] those are people
that were forced into having children
and they are psychologically incapable
of it and they just somehow found
themselves in a situation where the you
know they shouldn't ever have had access
to a child and they have one and they're
literally tasked with raising it and
that is what happens yeah